okay so our next talk I'll be given by
Michael Mahoney
here at UC Berkeley on randomize America
linear algebra sampling for linear
algebra statistics and optimization all
right thank you David so what's counts
as foundations of data so we've heard
about sampling and sketching and the
last day or two from one perspective and
a little bit of optimization today and
tomorrow and then some statistics
tomorrow and these are the things and so
I thought I've described a little bit at
least in a sense how to see how some of
the pieces fit together I think if
you've seen some of these things you see
how the pieces fit together but if you
haven't it might be a little bit
dizzying all the different things that
are going on and sampling arises in a
lot of different places
you know you can imagine there's a world
out there and you get data from the
world and you put it here and you want
to make inferences about the world I
mean that's one place sampling rises so
that's sort of the sampling in
statistics a lot of what we've been
talking about so far is sort of very
different than that right there's here
there's 100 machines and what you want
to do is too expensive and so I want to
down sample and get a sketch and so what
if anything is the connection between
those and I think if your backgrounds
sort of been computer science or
theoretical computer science you tend to
formulate problems and think about them
one way and that's rather different than
if your backgrounds in scientific
computing and numerical analysis how you
formulate and parameterize problems and
that's rather different than if you're
sort of background the machine learning
or statistics and yet all these sort of
ideas permeate through each of those
areas and so I thought I'd describe a
little bit about what I think sort of
makes these things work so they're
bridging some of the theory practice gap
connection so I'll talk about that and
that's sort of in the context of this
area sort of randomized linear algebra
so a little bit of background an
overview if you thought about this is
what the intent of boring you so the
first few slides will just sort of be a
little bit of background but the set
stage on the first hour I'll talk a
little bit about some sampling things
how they fit together and then the
second hour I'll get a little bit more
detail about a particular a couple
particular use cases
and so take take a step back so I we
were we wrote as an article I authority
article turn addison CA CM a couple
years ago and so we did due diligence to
sort of think about how this fit in the
broader landscape and I think that so
the matrices are very natural way to
model data and a data model something
means natural and computer science like
you know databases but less so l so but
it's a way to model data and it's it's
perfect or imperfect but it's a way to
model data so in particular you have an
M by n matrix and the M objects and n
features positive definite matrix and
codes correlations and that sort of
stuff and so as hopefully by now if
you've been here the last day or two
there's a lot of sort of exciting
developments motivated by a lot of
large-scale data processing using
randomization and so historically it's
sort of been assumed to be a property of
the data but you know meaning you
measure it from the world but you've
seen it use sort of as an algorithmic
resource or a computational resource so
what's what's the going on or what's the
connection so this randomized linear
algebra which is a theme of what we've
been talking about arises because in a
lot of cases you're modeling day as
matrices but you want to make
inferential claims about the world but
you also want to compute on stuff so
this is an area that's interdisciplinary
as you may have gathered and it uses
randomization as a resource to extract
insight from data which means you need
to understand these sort of two
complementary aspects so there's a very
foundational perspective right the roots
are in theoretical computer science a
lot of the techniques have connections
with convex analysis and probability and
metrics embeddings and so on and also
sort of applied math and computational
math and scientific computing from
implementations you know it's not
obvious but well engineered algorithms
in this space you know be tell a pack in
terms of wall clock time that was the
claim of been London pick result it has
been a range of results that are
following up on that using these things
as preconditioners and in terms of data
analysis strong connections with machine
learning and statistics so I think
there's a couple ways to view about this
and sort of today and this week and the
semester is viewing it sort of from the
context of foundations of data so how
broad or how narrow is this in scope so
take so linear algebra sort of as you
know so there's a long history and at
least by the standards of the day
large-scale data analysis so Gauss had
this algorithm in roughly oh one
for doing QR type decompositions
beginning of the next century Hotelling
and others developed PCA and this was
before computer science existed right so
people think there's noise in the data
and you compute something if there's
noise in the data then then
least-squares residuals are good in
certain senses and keeping lead
principle complements might be good in
other senses and so that's sort of the
motivation and what people have in the
back of their mind when they using this
and sort of having been said of doing
randomized linear algebra others it seem
to be sort of an interesting sort of
disconnect or change once you have the
development of the computer because it
wasn't obvious that you could invert a
matrix on a machine stabili right I mean
back in 1950 and so it's a big deal to
get that done and so I think culturally
a lot of scientific computing and random
and linear algebra sort of push
randomness out it entered into other
areas and so so this in a sense is
obvious but I wanted to emphasize this
because a lot of the particular
questions people ask have remnants from
this and so what you're seeing today
it's meeting and more generally is that
people sort of are inventing and
reinventing stuff that is grappling with
some of these issues and so it's the
early computer science and early
applications of linear algebra focused
on scientific computing problems and
there there's this notion that you only
want to solve well posed problems and so
even for well posed problems certain
algorithms might perform poorly so that
appears in numerical analysis but it
appears in statistics right you don't
wanna be solving poorly posed problems
they might not care about machine
precision they care about robustness and
posionous and different senses in early
work turing may be known for the term
machine but if your backgrounds in
numerical I also you know that he and
others had early work in numerical
analysis where they addressed these very
questions in this led to sort of problem
specific complexity measure sort of a
condition number so one notion of a
condition number is that top to bottom
eigenvalue you saw a different notion of
conditioning this morning for an
optimization problem so the point of a
condition number is it's a problem
specific or an input specific complexity
measure that says how hard is this input
for a specific class of algorithms we'll
get back to that and the traditional
condition number is how hard is this
input for a class of iterative
algorithms like conjugate gradient or
something
there was for a range of reasons sort of
a split and a lot of the continuous work
moved on into applied math and
scientific computing in a lot of the
discrete work went into computer science
you know it's easy to formulate
computation per se in discrete settings
you know there's a range of sort of
reasons for that
and so Rob you mentioned yesterday you
know if you were to ask a computer
scientist 20 or 30 years ago which of
these algorithms would perform well and
unscaled the data flow algorithms would
or something and that's exactly not what
happened
and so with respect to what he was
talking about yesterday do you want to
run an algorithm that gets all pairwise
distances right is that better or worse
than an algorithm that sort of gets some
all right on average and so this was the
difference between random projections
and SVD he talked about yesterday and so
one is obviously better if you view the
world one way and the other is obviously
better if you view the world the other
way and so under the hood and a lot of
we're talking about is is trying to
tease out which ones obviously better
and depending on the application because
if you using method a versus B versus C
you're implicitly using one or the other
and so let's sort of characterize that
so so this goes into it a little bit
more details more information in these
slides and I'm going to talk about so
for archival reasons but this will go
and put a little bit more detail about
that and so recently as you may have
gathered this sort of a convergence of
these perspectives and so I think this
has been motivated by large-scale data
so scientific internet a range of sort
of applications computation per se is
necessary you need to do it but it's not
sufficient most downstream users of
these things don't care about
computations per se and so if you
formalize stuff in a particular model
and you ask is this tight or is that so
the lower bound those are oftentimes
very brittle to the detailed models of
data access and so they break if you
consider something slightly different
and so most people want to gain insight
in terms of downstream predictions and
so central to a lot of these
developments is random sampling and
linear algebra randomize aspects of
linear algebra well you have randomness
is it in the data or is it in the
algorithm or is there a tension between
the tool maybe you can speed something
up and do better because of some
implicit statistical regularization
continuous versus discrete doer about
numerical issues and scientific versus
business type into your sort of data
motivations lead to very different types
of questions you want to ask so
sort of a good hydrogen atom in a couple
senses I mean one a lot of the questions
you might want to answer you can ask
much more simply in a linear algebraic
setting right how do you talk about
implicit regularization and a57 way or
neural network if you don't understand
that for least squares so a lot of the
themes are eyes here but also these
these sort of basic linear algebra
things appear but pulling them out and
talking about them sort of in isolation
oftentimes doesn't lead to the best
insight about how they might be useful
in in a pipeline and that pipeline could
be use it as a precondition or to solve
some other linear algebra to high
precision but it could be feed into an
iterative algorithm or feed into all
sorts of other stuff to use it for a
statistical inference so let's
understand sampling in a range of these
ways and view it sort of as a hydrogen
atom to understand these are the
foundations more generally so from that
perspective with that background so what
have you been talking about for the last
couple days so Basics in a randomized
linear algebra technique does the
following you have a data set it's
either in the world or on the machine
most of what we've been talking about
it's on the machine and you want to
construct some sort of sketch and that
sketch is typically done by sampling
something it could be elements could be
rows and columns but um you sample
something and you use that sketches of
proxy so you compute something on that
sketching you say it's good in some
sense for the original problem I had
that's the high level and so if you take
a step back there's a million moving
parts and a lot of projections and this
and that so I think the way to tax on
amides are to think about it is in terms
of basic design principles right if you
wanted to have good coding practice or
good theory practice the idea is
randomly sample so some matrices
whatever matrices about today about
their elements or Bay they about their
rows and columns some people say that
they're the rows and columns right if
you have the row space and the column
space you're good well this might say
you know if you have a term document
matrix I'm interested in this term in
this document if you have users and
preference as I mister than this user in
this preference of their elements so
either want a sample elements or you
want to sample rows and columns and in
general you want to do it in in a data
dependent way and in a smarter careful
way and then you use that as a sketch to
chew things but doing that sort of
naively you're doing that uniformly
typically does sub-optimally so use it a
but typically a naive way to compute the
data dependent structures you want
that's going to be expensive and so you
can approximate them and you heard about
approximating leverage scores or you can
pre-process a precondition so
preconditioning is a notion that doesn't
appear so much in computer science but
it's very common in numerical analysis
and the idea of preconditioning is I
have a problem and I transform it to a
different problem I solved this problem
the two solutions are the same or easily
related to each other all right
and so one answer is I transform it by
doing an identity transformation in
which case this is no easier than this
right another is I transform it by
computing the exact solution in which
case you know you've done a lot of work
to transformation so the question is is
there a trade-off space can I transform
it in a way that's quick and also such
that I can solve this more quickly and
so that is what random projections are
doing in in this case they rotate you to
a random basis where good things happen
so I'll give you some examples that but
hey that's thought there's that's the
way to think about a lot of these random
projections and how they're being used
so if you do element wise sampling you
know you're thinking of the matrix is a
bunch of numbers and you know your
sample uniformly or not over the numbers
and you know what does that mean that
could mean the data is here and I pull
out a few things it couldn't mean I
don't know if it was arrived or someone
yesterday I mentioned two techniques one
method
it could mean there's oh there's a world
out there and I'm a company I want to
measure do you have a preference for
this or that so I'll show you something
and if you click or not I sort of assume
that you have a preference for this and
so it could mean that I sort of
interrogate the hypothesized matrix
uniform sampling tends to lead to poor
results one thing that's been used a lot
is non-uniform sampling with respect to
the magnitudes of the elements so this
is the element wise analogue of the row
norm sampling so it's an l2 on the
elements and if you do that you tend to
get bounds of the following form so this
is a spectral norm bound a - the sampled
version and spectral norm this is a true
element wise but in terms of the
directions of variance that's better
than something times a scale if you have
this then you're going to get additive
error bounds and so you you know
additive our bounds yesterday you heard
we're bounds of the form I'm better than
best plus epsilon times some scale but
that scale could be large or small
and so if you're asking for something
very fine and that scale is huge you
might as well return nothing right I
mean because you're not gonna say
anything if that scale is pretty small
then you might be saying something so
we'll give you additive error bounds
which are good but not great and the
proof method uses ideas from random
matrix theory if you if you're familiar
with this so a different thing is the
sample rows and columns and you've seen
a lot of this and again uniform sampling
may perform poorly non-uniform sampling
does better so if you if you perform non
uniform sampling according to row
lengths this is what we've seen a couple
times yesterday you again get you know a
matrix multiplication result of this
form and if you get this result this is
a primitive we'll get back to but if you
have that result again for a low-rank
approximation and a range of other
things you get additive error bounds
right so you are as good as the best
rank okay that SVD gives you plus
epsilon times something large and that's
something large is here if you sample
uniformly that's something large would
be the dimension or the dimension
squared but that you want that something
large depends in the normal so is that
good or not if you're exactly ranked
okay if you're well approximated by low
rank that's not reflected here if the
overall mass of the matrix is in too
large that might be reflected so and
here the basic proof method is you look
at expectations and variances and more
sophisticated things for spectral norms
so when we first saw this this is a
little bit funny because you know you're
not doing anything better by looking at
rows and columns and elements and you
feel like you should because you're
capturing subspace structure and so what
can you do and so a different thing you
can do then the norm squared sampling is
used as leverage score sampling so this
is something that you know will
originally I guess Rene and I sort of
reverse engineered and then I turned out
have this interpretation and this is
looking at you know role norms of left
singular vectors which is equipment ly
diagonally laments of projection
matrices and I think the way to think
about it is it's relatively easy to
normalize rows and columns right you
just normalize them it's a little bit
harder to normalize away the subspace
structure right so if there's an example
of a of a problem you know where your
look like this
I asked you which data points can have
the biggest fit I mean any metric that's
reasonable is gonna find this one right
so this is one one you know leverage is
one way to capture that now do you want
to find this or not I'm gonna sample
this or not it depends if you're a
statistician you may give a very
different answer than if you're computer
scientist or if you're computer science
and you're making a claim about what's
sitting in front of you there's no world
you make an claim about what sitting in
front of you someone you're an algorithm
there's an input there's an output you
know you better be right
garbage in garbage out you better be
right so you want to find that if your
statistician you might say jeez you know
that's an outlier that's something funny
and I want to not find that empirical
questions maybe data look funny and
you're using least squares because
there's nothing else that you can use
but you know so you want to buy yourself
to its funny things and a lot of the
early work in theoretical computer
science because it's asking algorithmic
questions and computer science biases
you towards that and you may want to buy
us away you know away from that so
they're useful in regression Diagnostics
identify outliers like most things you
can be naive in their computation or not
to compute them exactly takes q/r time
or you know something like that as
you've heard you can compute them a
number of different ways and you heard
about one way in essentially random
projection time so the time it takes
implemented projection you can
approximate them there's a couple
different notions of approximation as a
practical matter in terms of use cases
you want to find a large ones and small
ones the first approximation don't
matter we'll get back on the second hour
to a case where they do but you can
usually easily take care of that and you
saw an example of this and in the
optimization talk this morning replace
the non-uniformity which is a variant of
this with half a non uniformity plus
half uniform that means nothing's too
small and so that's why she did that and
and there was a question about business
correspond to regularization and it
doesn't very natural sense the other
reason this was sort of of interest is
that it provides a data aware subspace
embedding meaning I look at the data I
know something about the data but but I
get an embedding which I said which I'm
saying if I have a rectangular
orthogonal matrix then if I'm tall
then you know I know that like this
that's an identity right I want to say
the sampled version of that is roughly
an identity and the way to quantify that
is to say that this - over the spectral
norm is the largest singular value
they're all one if they're all between a
half and three hats place that with an
epsilon I want to say strictly away from
zero why because if I prima tries
problems in a worst-case sense I'm dead
if I don't accomplish that in other use
cases it might be fine to violate that
and we'll see that but it gives you a
data where subspace embedding so from
the perspective of theoretical computer
science you've heard I think was
yesterday this should be thought about
is a subspace analog of Johnson Lyndon
Strauss right Johnson Lyndon thrust is
about a discrete point set but if you
put a ball unit ball on a low
dimensional subspace this is a subspace
analog of Johnson Lyndon Strauss
numerical analysts would actually think
of a very different way then say this is
an acute perturbation right
it's a perturbation that zeros out most
of the canonical axis and most of the
columns such that you don't lose rank
acute means it's less than 90 degrees so
you rotate a little bit you zero out
most things but you don't lose rank and
this is one way to think about it this
is a much more geometric way to think
about it and so neither is incorrect
both of the case and one of the others
more useful in certain use cases now
wrong you know norms of columns and
elements are not too hard these take a
bit more work even if it's random
projection time and so depending on your
use case you may want a precondition so
this is a good thing or not and so look
at numerical analysis book there's a
range of methods and it depends on the
problem depends on the input it depends
on the data presentation depends on a
lot of things and so similarly here so
the main challenge for a lot of these
things is that you want to find these
outline things you want to find these
interesting things so you can find them
or approximate them or you can just say
I don't care because I want to solve
this downstream thing the least squares
problem or something else and so what
I'm going to do is preprocessor
precondition my input and so the main
challenge for uniform sampling is that
there might be one or a small number of
coordinates that are that are
particularly important you know there
might be this guy there might be I think
someone put up a one negative one
one sort of example right you got to
find that guy so think of this as a
delta function right this is one
coordinate out of n that's important how
are you going to pre-process a delta
function you hit it with a Fourier
transform and it spreads it out to be a
sinusoid so Hadamard transforms gaussian
random projections count sketches all of
these things essentially rotate you to a
random basis with these things a uniform
with the leverage scores a uniform all
right so what why they work in a lot of
ways is causing the randomly rotated
basis that uniform eyes only
approximately right so Ken was talking
this morning the uniform eyes up to a
factor of two or ten I mean in that case
they could be uniform eyes only up to a
factor of login and that's sufficient
for what you want to do downstream so
that but they uniform eyes so that
should you ask for the constant factor
or the log in you this is a
pre-conditioner right depends on that
trade-off point you're interested in so
so you should think of it that way I
think all right so those little bit
about any pause for a second because I
want to go through a little bit of
detail the matrix multiplication and how
this is used in the least squares case
but maybe pause I forgot to bring the
water so I'll be okay but there's any
questions so hopefully this was a review
and maybe shed a light on some of the
things we've been talking about at least
didn't make it unclear and hopefully
clarify it a little bit it leads to
something yeah you have a pretty general
definition of pre-conditioner would you
describe sketch and swallow that's
precondition yeah so I don't know how
general you want to be it on let me get
back to that after the Lee's asked that
question after the least-squares sketch
it could be but then there's a precision
issue if you want a low precision it
could be because because according what
I just said the random projection would
would precondition in any sample
uniformly so for the class of sampling
matrices this is a pre-conditioner for
that and and you're not going to get
high precision because of the 1 over
epsilon and 1 over epsilon squared but
you'll get low precision so it would be
yeah so if you want a high precision you
got a couple this with a more
traditional pre-conditioner which is the
way they were you know David was talking
about it yesterday we had take this low
precision thing and then feed it took
more traditional high precision but
within the context of sampling albums it
is yeah
all right and so that question leads me
into a couple things actually not the
first thing you can see the second see
it on my screen but the first thing is
talking about matrix multiplication and
Nunley squares so
so how do you so sort of a primitive in
all of these things I think and you saw
one example of what the subspace
embedding is matrix multiplication right
so it could be simpler than this
so given an M by n matrix a they're all
in size n so you have an N by n matrix
and n by P matrix B approximate the
product and I think that when most
people at least initially see matrix
multiplication they think of it in the
following way I have a matrix a and a
matrix B and it's defined something I
mean your matrix multiplication is a
transformation it's a function right
it's not a bunch of elements but it's
defined operational in terms of elements
to say that a be you know IJ is a sum
over K of what of aik B KJ right meaning
it's a column of a and a row of whatever
a row of a and a column of B so that's
not untrue think of it this way though a
B is a sum
of outer products all right so you the
block by rows are blocked by columns if
you block a off by columns block B up by
rows a dot product each element of which
is a rank one matrix so think of it this
way and if you're dealing with rank one
matrices these are objects if you're
dealing with numbers these are other
objects and if you're summing over you
know one to a million of them you might
say sampling will work so that's what's
going on under the hood here and so
think of it as a sum of outer products
now don't think of it naively this way
because you know you might not access
the data this way but this is what's
going on under the hood I think and so
the sampling approach basically says you
know fix some set of probability is
whatever you want it could be what we're
talking about
I'll so you'll see in a second or it
could be other thing and 40 goes wanted
to see sometimes this is an S or an R or
an M or an M sub J it's the number of
samples you're drawing choose
a Rank 1 component but clearly don't
write it out naively choose a column of
a and a row of B with those
probabilities and so approximate the
product a B you know this is um whatever
K is equal to 1 to n if it's M by N and
n by P and say that this is close to a
sum from k equals 1 to C of a scaled
version you got a scale by that because
if I'm estimating the sum of a million
numbers by sampling 10 100 of them I got
a sale by was scaled by a million over
10 right so this is a non-uniform
analogue of that just to get estimators
to work so the same algorithm written as
in matrix notation pick a bunch of
columns of a and rows of B and write it
as an outer product that you feed
yourself through some low dimension if
you have this you know you can think of
this as a sampling matrix where this has
one nonzero parole and once you write it
this way you could say well what about
other matrices you're starting to
decouple the linear algebra from the
algorithmic property and then you can
say what if I had other so types of
things but for right now think of that
as a sampling matrix so if you do that
so there's simple as hard things right
so let's I'm trying to describe some
simple things and if you do what I just
said the following is simple in the
sense that if you no means and variances
you can prove the following so for any
set of sampling probabilities see R
equals a be element wise just right out
of saw minutes already set of
probabilities this is equal to the
variance it's something - of second term
which you usually drop if you're doing
balance all right
that's just write down means and
variances nothing fancy and so from
these it's easy to say that the
expectation of a B minus C R for B
Gnaeus squared but you can pull that off
as a sum of these things right so it's
it's you can get a bound on that you can
remove expectation with Markov
inequality or mark martingales and
arrange all the methods and buts
but they're sort of you heard about and
are sort of more standard but a little
bit more complicated
you could ask what's the set of
probabilities that optimizes this why
this because it's a convenient thing now
because it's the most important but
we'll see this is a useful primitive for
range of other things the probabilities
that optimize that so that that's a
reasonable notion not a perfect putting
a reasonable notion of quality the
property is optimized that of this so a
norm of a and a norm of B now if B
happens to be a transpose this is a norm
squared right divided by a Frobenius
norm so these are the optimal
probabilities if you use that than a B
minus C are lavinia norm of that is less
than 1 over root C this is the usual 1
over root C that you get in a Monte
Carlo method times the scale factor
which is norm of a times norm of B and
so in particular B is equal to a
transpose you're saying a a transpose
which of the form you've seen a bunch of
- call it C C transpose is less than 1
over root number of samples times the
norm of the matrix squared
and this is very robust if you
approximate this in any number of ways
it works you got to find the large
things you can miss small things if
you're off by a factor of two you get
over sample by a factor of two in worst
case but in practice you'll do a lot
better so they're very robust in in a
sense what is this thing this thing is a
complicated way of writing the spectral
norm of that thing this is a Rank 1
component so if I'm summing numbers you
know I'm going to say using any
probabilities I'm going to get a good
expectation but if I bias myself towards
large numbers I'm gonna get a good
variance it's not that this is saying so
bias myself towards large things large
matrices this is the matrix analog of
that if you estimate the height of
people it doesn't matter you choose
they're all everyone's about six feet
you choose a few hundred people you have
a good estimate if you try to estimate
wealth or something like that that has a
huge range
you better bias yourself in a better way
so that's all we're saying here bias
yourself towards larger things right
that's for being its norms think of
matrix multiplication is a primitive
that should feed other things into and
so for a lot of things you can use for
beanies gnomes you might need a spectral
mom but a spectral norm is less than a
4b Gnaeus mum so you could bound it that
way it's gonna be suboptimal but you
could you can use more direct methods so
there's a range of ways to do this which
here here's one result if you make the
spectral norm small on the Frobenius no
not too large I'm saying they're not
important here but the previous result
holds for anything this thing holds for
a subset of matrices it holds for
matrices that you're going to be
interested in that have a spectral
structure or something decays but it's a
subset of matrices if you sample with a
complexity that's slightly more
complicated looking but will be better
in practice then the spectral norm a a
transpose minus C C transpose can be
less than Epsilon so I'll say why this
matters and how this is related to the
previous thing but I wrote them in two
different ways just to highlight
something and so the way so the reason
why this is a primitive that's
interesting to feed into a lot of things
is so matrix multiplication will be the
primitive for a bunch of things and you
use better and worse bounds for a
sampling for projection for whatever
here's the 95 it's 99 but 95 or 98
percent use case so spectral norm bound
is better in the sense we'll get to here
but it's it's less general in in the
sense that it holds for B equals a
transpose it doesn't hold for arbitrary
a because those two conditions basically
you need to have a low soft relatively
low soft rank and so and so better
results in matrix multiplication
propagate to a lot of downstream things
and so we're talking about here the
sampling case the same is going to be
true on the projection case and you
heard a bunch about that so the main use
case for the spectral norm bound is the
following I have a matrix a which you
know getting the letters right as always
a mess so this is consistent the
previous page but not other talks and so
on so you know now I'm calling it a
transpose but let this be at all
orthogonal matrix namely let it be this
thing
and what I want to say is that u
transpose U is an identity and I want
the sampled version if u transpose U to
be roughly an identity and a way to
quantify that is to say that all the
eigenvalues of u trends of the sampled
version of u transpose u are close to 1
so meaning the spectral norm the largest
deviation 1 - this is less than 1/2 in
order to do that I can use the result
but the Frobenius norm results I had two
slides ago to say that the spectral norm
is less than the Frobenius norm the
roubini enorm is 1 over root C times the
norm of a but a here is an orthogonal
matrix so the Frobenius norm of u
what's the Frobenius norm of an
orthogonal matrix have a tall matrix
it's a million by ten orthogonal columns
am i standing in the way or is the
answer still up I don't know if you get
to see you can so if you've an
orthogonal matrix the Frobenius norm the
sum of the leverage scores is low
dimension it's ten it's not a thousand
so the reason this is a bit of interest
as opposed to add of scale factors is
that if you sum from 1 to n more or less
anything you're going to get something
like n unless you have some structure
here and so the reason the leverage
works is because if some is 10 more
generally what if it's 11 you try and
generalize this to other problems to
other objectives if the sum of the
leverage or influence or sensitivity
this generalizations is low dimension or
low dimension squared then you can
typically take advantage of it if it's
high dimension or root high dimension
you got to eat that in general so that's
why this works so you say that this is
the 4b Gnaeus norm squared is d the low
dimension divided by root C that's going
to be a problem because that should be
probably DC squared
see so this should be a square root of D
I guess yeah this this should be a
square root of D meaning that if I want
to make this less than 1/2 C needs to be
d squared over 2 or something right and
that d squared is gonna appear
everywhere right well we're doing Q R
it's high dimension low dimension
squared if we need the number of samples
to be d squared that's going to
propagate down we can make it less than
that we're gonna win and so the way you
win is by looking at a spectral norm
bound directly the thing I had on the
previous slide if you instantiate it's
gonna be log something like log C over C
times the Frobenius norm times a
spectral norm that should be root D not
D with the spectral norm of an
orthogonal matrix it's 1 so it's a root
D times 1 over root C times the log
factor and so I'll be able to use a
matrix multiplication primitive I could
use it for beanies and boils down to
matrix multiplication but that's
suboptimal if I use a spectrum directly
then I'm gonna need C to be D over
epsilon off the log factor so this is
where the win is and that's true in the
data aware case that oblivious case
that's going to be true everywhere what
if instead of having a sampling matrix
are at one nonzero Perot I have two non
zeros Pirolo or n non zeros Perot where
the n non zeros or gaussians or Hadamard
around markers or any of all the same to
first order the second of order there's
different log log log log differences
right but the first order and so lots of
lots of dense sampling matrices from a
theoretical computer science
perspectives and natural interpretation
terms of johnson lyndon Strasse and a
random projection and the subspace
embeddings as I said can be viewed as as
a sort of vector space generalization of
that in the random eye and the linear
algebra are thinking of it as a rotation
roughly an orthogonal transformation the
randomized Hadamard is is exactly an
orthogonal transformation the other ones
are approximately and natural
interpretation in terms of
preconditioning or pre-processing
so I'll get to that in a second so this
is - so hopefully this was clear by now
but to relate back to what you're
hearing about earlier some space
embedding is that you know I preserve
the geometry search so this is the
expression if you remember the
definition of a spectral Marmite a
spectral norm is the largest direction
that a unit like vector gets stretched
you can write it as whatever as max you
know you X over the unit length X that's
what this is so with the expression we
saw before is exactly this which is
exactly this lots and lots of
constructions some of them I've
described the data aware ones bias
yourself towards important things
there's lots and lots of data oblivious
so this was first used in it's in the
data where context it actually predated
the randomized the fast random I the L
and chose L result then Sarlo support if
you use couple this with the ion shell
result and there's been a lot of
follow-up in a date of livius way so you
want to use a result in this area should
you use the projection art should you
use a sampling method
was the first burger if you're gonna use
a result that we're talking about here
should I be using should I suggest to
use a projection method or a sampling
method so I don't have a suggestion it
depends on you and your problem for
certain problem sampling is more natural
for other problems you know projections
will be better but they're going to boil
down to the same thing under the hood so
don't think of it that way as I said
this is an acute perturbation meaning
it's a small rotation from a million
dimensions down to ten or a zero out but
not to 10 to 20 you know to 10 log 10 on
her eyes zero out most of the entries
but I don't lose rank in particular so
one of the points is this is sort of a
must-have you view things from a
computer science perspective you need
this in a lot of ways you know it's good
to have or it's good to have something
related to this but you can relax on
this what if you lose one or two
dimensions is at the end of the world so
I'll give an example of the answer to
that what if you want to you know do
something statistical where there's a
bias-variance tradeoff so how would this
generalize in those cases so I'm going
to give the least-squares example but
let me pause and see if there's any
questions or violent objections or
violent questions or nonviolent
objections
we're just talk about data oblivious
like the whole thing was looking at so I
didn't talk about it because I was able
to backward point to everyone else if if
they if ESO
so if you have a dense sampling mate so
the reason you need this sample is if I
just choose one thing I need to find
this one outlying thing if my sampling
matrix is dense meaning I have a plus or
minus one and every entry if I have a
Gaussian and every entry I have
something else if I make this quote
sampling matrix dense it's not a
sampling matrix its sampling a linear
combination of things which is a random
projection with some and so the count
sketch is is a very structured way to do
it that allows you to get extremely
sparse the the randomize Hadamard is a
way to do it that as a hierarchical
structure so you can implement it with
fast fourier techniques I mean gaussians
have other so when you make this dense
but the reason it's nice to distill this
out is to first order exactly the same
analysis works if you sample in a smart
way if you do data oblivious projections
if you do any of a range of things this
is a structural thing you need to
satisfy and so should you do it in the
data oblivious way or should you do it
in the data wear way and so the answer
is the same as it depends on the context
alright so at least squares so I like
these squares because every time we get
a new result you realize you didn't
quite understand something about what
was going on and so again dwell on this
we've been talking about this but so
this has been something that's been
studied forever right but I mean we're
looking at in a new light and so one
think of it where I'll describe some
stuff you've heard the last day or two
in a way that complements I mean so if
some of the previous talks have
emphasized numerical things I would have
taken the counterpoint and described
that maybe complementary to the TCS
approach so think of this as in light of
that but also distill out structural
properties like matrix multiplication
and where that might be used there so
think of this as a test case for saying
you know how would matrix multiplication
be used here so least squares minimize
ax minus B and now we're m-by-n I guess
and so in a Ram model this actually is
you know a far from perfect guide to
practice even on a single machine but
you know it's it's high dimension times
low dimension squared time
so far the other reason to distill out
the structural properties is what if
anything that we're talking about here
ports to a distributed data center if
you distill out the structural
properties you can deal with that
separately from RAM and other issues and
a statistical question you can ask
different questions whereas if you don't
distill that is much harder to figure
out what's going on
so for least squares is a nice example
here because it uses these techniques
and and you get the best results and you
get the best results for very different
and rather sort of inconsistent metrics
but you need to use the sort of basic
method in somewhat different ways so if
you want the the the algorithm that in
terms of worst case Ram running time and
RAM beats the algorithm Gauss had 401 an
algorithm here will do that so you can
use randomized Hadamard and then
depending on aspect ratios you can use
nnz type methods it's not obvious that
if you can make a statement like that
that the method is anything to do with
something that would perform well
numerically it turns out you can beat la
pack and wall clock time and then when
blend depicted that la pack respondent
and those an arms race so I don't know
what the state of the art is right now
but you can compute things you know you
can use these methods and feed them into
low-rank approximation z' and get pca on
50 terabytes of data 30 terabytes of
data sort of thing and the underlying
embeddings and approximation techniques
are the same but clearly the way it
implemented is going to be very
different and it's useful in a range of
data applications and sometimes useful
for very different reasons right it's
useful not because we've squeezed the
last little bit of out and objective but
there might be implicit regularization
right if you're using sampling the noise
inside the algorithm might synergize
well or poorly with noise in the
generative processes of the data so
least squares and so there's two there's
two notions of conditioning here so this
slide hopefully is a review by now one
is sort of
four four four low precision solutions
you need to capture something about the
non-uniformity on the canonical axis and
for high precision solutions you need to
compute the capture something about the
aspect ratio of the quadratic well that
sort of implicitly they're condition
number is the ratio of maximum and eigen
value it captures the one non-uniformity
on leverage or influence the sensitivity
scores either the max to the min or the
max to the average and depending on the
exact rejected you care about is a
condition number for a class of sampling
algorithms these have to do with eigen
vectors these have to do with eigen
values that is different and in real
cases generative processes the data
sometimes they're correlated especially
on extreme eigen values and eigen
vectors but you know in general they
could be whatever these are for l1 norms
as generalizations l2 norms as
generalization for r1 norms you heard
this morning a variant of these for an
optimum interative first-order type of
optimization algorithm so that's not
exactly this but it's it's a first
cousin of this in the context of of an
iterative optimization algorithm so
here's the basic least squares algorithm
compute this non-uniformity structure
randomly sample a small number of
constraints to it and then solve the
subproblem so this is sketch and solve
give me a sketch solve naive version I
like I'm the one of these emblems I like
this result because it's a core of a lot
of things but it gives you worse than
the exact answer it may fail with some
probability Delta and its running time
is worse so that doesn't seem to suggest
much for it but in fact I'm all those
can be taken care of so a non naive
version as I said is the best worst-case
algorithms and good for all sorts of
other things so let's understand what's
going on here
and that picture here is this this
picture find an outlier this is a pip
this is either the genome research of
the PNAS paper so the the genome
research at some stuff in genetics the
PNAS we looked at something else
question-how uniform or not of these is
this correlate at all with something
that might appear in practice and so
what you have here is is snips snips
single nucleotide polymorphisms a single
positions in the DNA where you're going
to have some difference between people
and the y-axis is here is a notion of
leverage this is a low-rank
approximation a generalization we've
been talking about and the things that
stick up our flag is that's higher
leverage than that now if you ask a
geneticist what are the important snips
here and say give me the 50 most
important snips that you have certain
metrics one is called informativeness
it's related mutual information they'll
take these the ones in red so there's a
strong correlation here and this is not
a one-off but it's probably a 50 off so
there's lots and lots of examples where
the non-uniformity structure you see in
very real data look something like this
so you might say why is this you know if
you're using an l2 metric shouldn't you
use an l3 or some other metric right and
the answer is people do least squares
and people do PCA and people do all
sorts of things like this not because
they really believe the generative
process is a Gaussian but because that's
something that they can compute and
scale and so on right and so looking for
outliers that could be a mistake you
kick your machine that could also be an
outlier that's the most interesting snip
relative to a model that you know it's
wrong but you're using for convenience
this is a very common thing so these
things are outlying so I mean I remember
we were working some people up the hill
at LBL
and they applied our method on some mass
spec data and it returned garbage and
they went and complained and said your
method didn't work I said what I mean it
didn't work and he said he returned
garbage I said how did you clean up the
data he said we cleaned it up
show me the garbage and of course it was
it was all artifacts of experiment yeah
the experimental setup that didn't
matter for other things that were using
but that that we have a method that
finds those found those I said why don't
you just remove all those run the
algorithm again you found these things
that you failed to clean up before
that's fine we run the algorithm again
then it zoomed in exactly on the outline
things that that they were interested in
so again should you by yourself towards
these or use these to filter the data
all right so there's almost all that
maybe I'll just have one question last
for the next hour right so it depends if
it depends on the use case I won't
promise maybe there'll be a different
question coming up so but so this this
is the way to think about this is
a structural result if you're modeling
data as a matrix in a Hilbert space or
you put in space this is a very basic
structural result I mean for L two
objectives it is not possible for every
data point to have a big influence on
the least squares fit that's what it
means at the sum of the leverage scores
are small in theoretical computer
science and I'll go into this more or
less detail the next hour depending on
time but you can event objectives
there's lots of objectives and for some
of those objectives that some of the
sensitivities is small you can use
sampling techniques for other of those
objectives are some of the sensitivities
is the high dimension you can't use
sampling techniques at least not in
worst case of course you can regular
eyes and do lots of other rigmarole but
that's the that's leading order bit so
for these objectives it can't be the
case that every data point is important
so that's why sampling would work all
right so yeah there's a sketch in solve
so we can make this algorithm fast by
running in RAM we can make at I
precision so how do you make it fast
use a Hatter martin method use account
set sketch method use any of a range of
methods you've been talking about or
compute fast approximations to the
leverage scores you know how we saw this
morning you know you have your your
matrix a oh oh now I won't use a QR
inverse and I won't use a you are all
starting to Michael Saunders before the
talk he was complaining that you are
I'll use a QR so a you know is equal to
QR that's expensive to compute let's
work on PI a what is that this is
anything but in particular it's a
Hadamard based projection Gallinas if
you like that as a count sketch let's
say PI a is equal to Q hat R hat that's
exactly our thought oh that's perfect
numerical issues and whatever but that's
perfect for that in particular if you
were to look at PI a R inverse you know
you have an orthogonal matrix apply it
up here a R inverse this is equal to Q
hat hat that's not our thought at all
there it is the right dimensions and
it's close to our thuggin all what sense
is a close to orthogonal in the sense
that
do you transpose Q minus Q hat hat
transpose Q 1/2 hat spectral norm so
there's matrix multiplication sense
alright and there you know you need to
wedge an extra projection in there to
make things fast and so long that that's
the structure that makes that work and
you can make it high precision so you
heard yesterday about one way to do this
a different way is to call LS QR or you
know which is which is conjugate
gradient in the normal equation sort of
done right so you don't mess up
condition numbers and if you have any
questions about that I'll pass the buck
to Michael Saunders who can probably
answer it in more detail so you know if
you're interesting that sort of stuff
call that as a black box because that's
been stress tested for 30 years over now
there's LS some are mrr mrr mrr
LS mr so i'll give a plug to LS mr which
is the new but you have call that black
box and how are you going to do that so
i'm saying you'd preconditioning here
you could take this wherever
if I'm solving ax minus B
pre-multiplying off by Q transpose by Q
hat hat transpose call ellis mr so what
makes all this work
X minus B there's a solution ax op so
this is clean because there's you can
write it in a nice clean form the unit
of algum is a little bit more
complicated because you can't write that
in a nice clean form so you need to do
something iterative as well as a
preconditioned version so then I slipped
in a new letter that's an ass or maybe a
pie but this is just your sketching
matrix so here's the basic structural
result if Sigma min so we know that the
eigenvalues of u singular values of u
are one if Sigma min of the sketched
version of U is greater than a half you
can actually be bad on the upside but
say it's less let's say it's between a
half and three halves and if you a
dotted into B perp what's B perp B perp
is the part of be sitting outside the
column space of a so you a got into B
purpose zero if you a dot in the B perp
on your sample it is close to zero less
than epsilon that times a scale where
the scale is a thing there's a number
you're computing here if this is true
then your relative error you plug your
solution back in ax minus B u 1 plus
Epsilon good there's no difference
between the two norms you want plus up
some good does it
you know condition number factor there
of course so this is a structure result
there's no randomness in the statement
all right and so this was the original
result when we first had the relative
error result and there's no randomness
in the statement so you could use the
left singular vectors as Omega
maybe not quick to compute them but you
could you could use any matrix you want
you could run an algorithm and you could
check these conditions after the fact so
it just so happens that if you use
leverage sampling or if you use random
projections or if your guarantee of a
subspace embedding you satisfy these in
a sense that computer science like worst
case a priori balance but you could run
something and fail to satisfy the worst
case a prior bounds but ask can I
certify that these are true and so you
know this is a struct result there's no
randomness here and both conditions are
approximate matrix multiplication right
the first one eigen values are one I
want the sampled versions to be close to
one and the second one that's zero right
so the second one is an approximate
matrix multiplication result here you
don't need the high probabilities and
all that rigmarole this this is
sufficient but you could do that if you
wanted all right
lots of constructions satisfy this heavy
hitters I mean there's frequent items
emitters of things the analysis I wasn't
present in this way but you can feed it
through a result like this and this is
of the basic structure result to get
least squares approximation if you're
interested in the data in front of you
date on the machine if you're sitting
the world that's we'll get to that later
but this is of the basic structure
result and yeah you know I used to worry
about this but you know I'd say be a
little cavalier about the excellence
theoretically you know in theoretical
few times you tend not to care about it
and numerical people precondition they
used to early work here they used to
worry about it a lot and this used to be
a big sort of point of criticism but
said epsilon to be a half
you have a good pre-conditioner and you
take two extra iterations or something
right this is a trade-off point you can
make it one over 100 but set it to be
half and in machine learning and data
analysis is just different pain points
and here's the plots for blended pick
that says you know you can be tell a
pack something that I learned here that
part should have an obvious but I didn't
know part of this so a subspace
embedding is is sufficient to get a good
pre-conditioner but you know is it
overkill all right what if you know in
random matrix three people look at the
spectrum random matrices and they look
at the tails and you know you might ask
could I get greedy
you put a sample a lot less than the de
over epsilon and log factors go to ten D
so if you do that you'll fail in worst
case so you know we know that and it may
be the case that on any particular input
you fail so I want to do sketch and
solve that's a problem because maybe I
failed to find the one thing I want if
I'm gonna use that as a pre-conditioner
that's not such a problem and basically
the reason is that if you're going to
use this and you're going to say this is
a good pre-conditioner and you're going
to call the black box what if I have
something else that's a rank one
perturbation of a good pre-conditioner
they lost one dimension or rank three
perturbation of a good pre-conditioner
they're lost three dimensions I need to
do 3 X 2 iterations or something they're
just a few extra iterations so you can
get much greedier on the down sampling
step if you're using in the pipeline the
simplest version of that is an iterative
police square solver but there's many
other examples of that all right that I
don't know you probably hear tomorrow in
this context of second-order
optimization which uses these things and
generalizations of these ideas but a GPU
implementation so I don't know the
answer we just have don't have the
implementation of the straightforwardly
squares on the GPU probably wouldn't be
too hard but this is a few years old and
the LS RN which is the extension is to
use random bits with Gaussian matrices
there's also a few years ago so I don't
know yeah I don't know how it would
perform on a GPU
good question if someone's numerically
inclined is it slow it's actually a very
low hanging fruit all the
infrastructures in place so we would
know Eddie something but I don't know I
don't know all right so one through
matrix multiplication because I you know
feel like if if you see that and how
that relates to theoretical computer
science objectives like Johnson Lyndon
Strasser all and get every pair wise
things and you know if I lose a
dimension or two how its you so I wanted
to go through the matrix multiplication
perimeter then go through least squares
primitive and then waving my hands and
say you know so that all boils down to
that which is a bit of an
oversimplification but if you if you
think about these things a lot does bow
down so I want to give a little bit
example just sort of how a bunch of
different low rank things do boil down
to this and then maybe you'll believe
that a lot of other things almost do so
it was so how it go had a nice so this
is extending some stuff Tygart had and
there was a range of scientific
computing people who've got
implementations and of course they don't
like the log factors and and and for
good reason I mean it's just not a way
that they had implement things and they
said how do these things perform in
practice and they would describe it the
typical use case they're a scientific
computing you're not doing matrix
multiplication but really you are on the
hood you're not doing these squares but
really we're out of the hood but you
think this is a matrix and the matrix is
a discretization of a continuous
differential operator and you want
typically you know medium to high
precision because you're solving a PDE
or you're solving a climate model you're
solving some scientific so there's been
a lot of attention in geophysics and
Geosciences
using these methods and so that's sort
of one and and and are they asking a
very similar question or a different
question so the way they describe it is
the following I want to I have a matrix
a it's you know both dimensions are
large it's not rectangular and I specify
a target rank and then I don't say K log
K over up so I specified over sampling
parameter P that's five and I want to
sample K plus five dimensions and so I
want to get factors u Sigma B transpose
that approximate a in some sense so they
typically are thinking low numerical
rank meaning you know fifty vectors
gives the Machine precision so there's a
difference there most data applications
a thousand vectors gives you
50 percent the Frobenius mass which
means things are very different so they
would say draw and an N by K plus P
Gaussian random matrix
form the N by K plus P sample matrix Y
which was eight times Omega which is
your your PI compute northa normal basis
for that form of small matrix B is equal
to Q transpose a back to the small
matrix and the u hat Sigma B transpose
and then form U is equal to Q u hat so
you know a numerical analysis you
probably familiar with that otherwise it
you know it's not clear what the 1 step
of the other might be doing you can
prove bound to the following form so a
minus the projection onto the columns is
this is the residual for B Gnaeus mass
and it's 1 plus something of the form K
over P and in spectral norm it's
something having to do the best rank K
spectral norm plus something else this
is this is a 4b Gnaeus norm so it's best
rank K times the little multiplicative
factor plus something else that's large
so how does this relate to we were
talking about and what's the underlying
structural results here P equals one
looks a bit dangerous what they would
suggest is five or ten or no what they'd
say but the the code that happened be
five or ten the probability so here
we're we're doing a low-rank thing and
if you keep a few extra dimensions which
we didn't have in the least-squares case
results get much better if you keep a
few extra dimensions but not one you
know that say five or ten this is what
they'd say meaning you go to their paper
that's what they say I'll roll I mean
how do you relate it back to other
things and so so so so if they change
the analysis that may or may not be good
for the use case so the question is what
question are you asking what questions
should we be asking so so in a sense I'm
just describing a history and they would
do this thing and make a big deal about
how it sounded different they would you
know we you would say oh you can change
this and ask this other thing they would
say yeah but this other thing you did we
could change it and ask it our way I'm
just trying to say yeah what sort of
similar but um what's the connection
between this and everything we've been
talking about and to highlight that I'll
say how would you prove a structure
result like that a seemingly very
different question is see you are you
heard the other day or CSSP the column
subset selection problem so I have a big
matrix given me the K columns that are
best
that's intractable for any notion of
best so give me the k plus p or k plus
ten or K log K and there's a range ways
to quantify that but I want the best
columns so what if anything does that
have to do with bounds of this form it
seems like a very different problem it
is so under the hood they're gonna be
very similar so this is so I showed you
before a structural result that underlie
you know the 99% cases as long as you
gotta be a little bit cavalier about log
log factors this is the similar thing
for low-rank approximation and this was
first highlighted by blue Cetus and in
in the column subset selection but it's
used in as though the basis for a lot of
the numerical
methods so a minus the projection on to
a is that rank K or not and so that's a
second-order bits there could be slight
differences here for what norm spectral
Frobenius trace so it basically holds
for any unitary variate norm and then it
bifurcates depending on what you have
because you don't have matrix
multiplication result so although it's
better than best rank k plus this so
what is this form this is top k singular
vectors perpendicular i mean the bottom
n minus k singular vectors times best
rank k bi times the complement to the
best rank EK what is best rank K times
the complement of the best rank K 0 I
want to say that best rank K times
complement of best rank K is roughly 0
so you have this result this is a
deterministic statement you could ask
for an a part by re bound and a
posteriori bound subset selections do
random rotations do Nystrom the nice
term you want to preserve symmetry and
positive definite there's a psych tweak
on those properties but it's a very it's
a first-order similar so given the
structure result wide range of sort of
low rank approximations will follow so
this is a basic structure result that
extends in a special case of this as the
least squares but this is a more general
thing because of the little space so
this is what we'll cover in the next set
of half-hour so this is some of the
basics and you can use it in a lot of
different ways and I'll highlight a few
ways that are ways that other people
this week aren't going to be talking
about in the next hour so some of these
things you heard from some of the other
speakers and I'll hide a few that how it
a few that other people aren't gonna be
talking about in the next hour
[Applause]
since for Michael to this no I can't
proximation
doesn't that fall out from the matrix
multiplication stuff that anybody
identity yeah so I mean this will reduce
to least squares which will reduce to
make it multiplications what's the
difference that's I mean this is a
projection that's the only thing people
only care about the outcome being ranked
a rank P here and can I just use one of
those it's this transpose is sort of
cute yeah this is the question that
asked they they would describe it
differently and they would talk about
Gaussian based projections and the
structural result to justify this is the
one on the next slide with that
structure result you could do what
you're talking about you know change
change the projection as long as you
satisfied those conditions you get us an
analogous in a statement yeah
let's thank Michael game
[Applause]